l'uniforme du milicien ça n'a jamais été
un choix pour Ali son destin allait
toujours être celui de cet homme qu'il a
à peine connu
son père Karim est mort alors qu'il
n'avait que deux ans
en 2004 leader murtadal Sadel a proclamé
une résistance un combat contre
un jeune homme à l'époque est allé les
combats
américaine de l'Irak le dirige ensuite
avait alors fourni sa propre milice elle
a combattu violemment les troupes
étrangères et semer la terreur en Irak
accusé de mener des commandos de la mort
contre les Irakiens d'autres confessions
religieuses
requête pendant l'Occupation il se
cachait à
l'endroits ils l'ont retrouvé un groupe
de soldats est venu et ils l'ont abattu
de trois balles
les Américains ne sont plus des ennemis
ce qui reste sont les alliés de l'armée
nationale et par ricochets de groupe
armés qui ont combattu un nouvel
envahisseur les tailles islamiques mais
ça ne rend pas la résistance armée moins
essentielle pour Ali
au nom de Dieu nous luttons contre les
oppresseurs ceux qui sont contre la
vérité contre ceux qui nient les droits
des pauvres qui les combattent
Saddam Hussein l'occupation américaine
le gouvernement actuel tous ceux qui ont
dirigé l'Irak depuis 20 ans ont opprimé
son peuple croient tali une pensée en
parfaite harmonie avec son dirigeant si
le gouvernement reste comme il est il
n'y a pas d'avenir le partage du pouvoir
fait en sorte que tout le monde défend
ses propres intérêts ces profits ça pour
les sunnites ça pour les chiites ça
divise ça n'a aucun sens
sur ce point Mohamed est entièrement
d'accord le jeune activiste se rappelle
avoir foulé le sol de la place d'arrière
en 2019 aux côtés de milliers d'autres
manifestants il espérait un changement
radical de la gouvernance de son pays
ses espoirs ont été brutalement éteints
la répression était évidente les
meurtres nous les avons vus 800
personnes sont mortes des milliers
d'autres ont été blessés ou sont portés
disparues
a fondé une ONG qui vient en aide au
patient atteints de cancer une affaire
personnelle pour lui il souffre d'une
leucémie depuis l'adolescence une
conséquence directe de la guerre
croatiele
c'est une maladie chronique mon seul
espoir c'est une opération mais je pense
que c'est autour de 60000 dollars
américains et je dois aller en Inde
il lutte pour sa survie mais son combat
pour l'Irak n'en est pas moins vital
Émilie armées l'ingérence étrangère de
l'Iran surtout la corruption et
l'incompétence sont autant de métastases
qui ronge son pays
les manifestations je disais que ce sont
eux les vrais cancers qu'il faut les
éliminer après on pourra se débarrasser
des cancers dans nos corps
Ali est né à Bagdad tout juste après la
chute de Saddam Hussein mais aujourd'hui
c'est à airbil capitale du Kurdistan
irakien quel prix les 20 dernières
années en Irak n'ont été qu'une longue
suite de trauma de violences et d'exode
pour les communautés chrétiennes avant
l’évasion américaine ils étaient environ
un million et demi aujourd'hui les
chrétiens sont à peine 500 000 selon les
estimations les plus optimistes
[Musique]
sa famille s'accroche à l'Irak mais elle
n'a plus revu le quartier de Bagdad qui
l'a vu grandir depuis 2012
beaucoup de gens ont été tués surtout
des chrétiens on leur a volé leur maison
aussi un oncle enlevé assassiné la
maison familiale incendiée des amis dans
la rue elle raconte une enfance marquée
par la violence sans jamais perdre le
sourire
je me souviens que il y a une bombe dans
notre école alors que nous étions des
enfants
ils nous ont dit de rentrer chez nous
c'était un jour terrible je me souviens
de la vie très éclatée et une fille a
perdu ses yeux elle ne peut plus voir
l'histoire douloureuse des chrétiens
allait se poursuivre avec l'arrivée des
groupes djihadistes Al-Qaïda il estïta
islamiques
nous n'avons pas de problème avec les
musulmans ou les gens d'autres religions
ce n'est pas des Irakiens ordinaires
dont on parle ils sont bienveillants
amicaux ils sont
bonsoir mais ceux qui sont en haut de la
pyramide sont ceux qui détruisent des
relations entre les gens de différentes
confessions et toute la société
une destruction qui se poursuit
croit-elle encore aujourd'hui si la
jeune peintre rêve de revoir Bagdad au
grand don de ses parents restent lui
rêve de quitter un pays qui pour lui
n'en est pas un une
vous savez pourquoi nous ne sommes pas
un pays parce qu'on n'est pas bon les
uns envers des autres nous avons un cœur
noir entre nous
[Musique]
une noirceur dont racis a pris
conscience à la mort de son père il
était dans les forces des pêches mergat
et combattait le groupe état islamique
il est mort loin de la ligne de France
assassiné en sortant de la mosquée après
la prière du vendredi
la vie dans les différents cycles de
violence qui ont ponctué les courte vie
de ces jeunes que nous avons rencontré
une statistique on peut vite de sens
dans toute sa magnitude mais une à une
c'est mort violente sont un héritage
lourd à porter pour ceux qui restent
[Musique]